with a whole process of denial and
repression and I think that what's
really significant is that for many
years now people who were trying to deny
that it ever happened that it ever
happened to them or if it did happen
they did afflict them in any in any in
any particular way so that it's better
to forget about it you shouldn't be
talking about it was father will get
upset
I'll get my nightmares mother will cry
so let's pretend it's never been it's
never happened and personally speak
again see I I was I was unable to read
any books for instance about the
Holocaust
I've until very recently I'm up James
with one word about the Holocaust I was
never able to watch any movies about the
Holocaust of life and I was pretending
very hard it never happened to me don't
anyway cut a long story short my wife
said well you know we've been trying to
run away for a long time - why don't you
confront it and there were very very
interesting psychologically interesting
things that happened since but the most
important was that for this first time
there was this whole of costs moving on
on television
it's unimportant it was good or a
statistically good or whatever so for
the first time I decided to watch it
with my family and it was a moving
experience okay so at one point by the
end of it we were all crying and my 9
year old daughter said to me hey daddy
you crying I said yeah and you're crying
too
she said yeah but well I cry from time
time that I've never seen you cry so I
really know I'm human I do cry from time
to time to be not as much as you do but
at home I can remember times when I
cried
that's why don't cry here and she said
well I I cry for all those protocol so
why do you cry I said I don't know I
really try for myself because she said
what you mean for yourself I said well
you know I was a part of it I went
through those miseries and she never
knew who I didn't you tell me for once
in my life I was speechless I realized I
wasn't able to tell her and although you
know we have very good communication
which we talked about more service
injuries I was born in Krakow Poland and
1938 March 1938 to open with his last
family my father was a lawyer my
grandfather was a wealthy merchant and
dealer in precious gems when the war
broke out the worst the possibility to
run away and financially speaking
problem my family had the finances to
run away that my grandfather ruled
against against it and being no
old-world
patois type of person so of course once
you ruled there was nothing to do and
his rationale was that he has known the
Germans for all his life he knows the
culture knows the people he's been
trading dealing with the Germans all his
life and he knows that
crystals are honest cultural
hard-working the best people in the
world people at the time didn't really
believe I did anyone and on the world
believed it something like that might
happen so my father and the data all
under German occupation being a Zionist
leader he was trying to talk people into
going into hiding into running away and
so on so forth he was considered at that
times was around the year 1940 1941 that
he was at that time and before this he
was considered as a madman no one would
listen
in 1942 we were moved
to the ghetto together at one point was
still open which means that we could go
to the outer city okay and I remember
distinctly one thing that my grandmother
was a very religious and very old dogs
person told my mother to go out and take
me with her and to buy some to buy me
some ham now had more Samson was never
seen in our household being as always
just and my grandmother said well you
know this is the food that you can give
the child but I don't want it in this
house so don't bring it home I think
that it's registered to me because it
was maybe the first double message of
the kind of another message that I ever
heard and therefore I distinctly
remember not exactly understanding why
did she say it's okay to buy it
but don't bring it home so all the years
afterwards I realized what this woman
really went through probably in order to
know to try to somehow supplement the
diet and then my first ice a very vivid
memory very vivid memory was around this
time which must have been the winter of
1914
and I was about four and a half years
old I was sick I had been inflammation
within a year just in terrible pain and
they had to take me to the doctor and I
was crying and but there was a curfew at
that time for some reason there was a
curfew until 4:00 o'clock good afternoon
so my father was very impatient to take
me to the doctor to have my ears pierced
and my drums pierced and once it was
four o'clock he took me on his arms and
we went out of the house on the sidewalk
and right to the entrance
this Aveda the entrance was this German
soldier I can see the perfect hear the
click of the which you know when it was
loaded and I can still hear my father
crying
very high-pitched voice and this season
miss Susan don't shoot don't shoot it
sir the curfew is over and this guy was
a German soldier stopped he looked at
his watch and it was four o'clock so we
lowered the rifle
and we are allowed to go in beginning of
1943 the cattle was closed down we were
more to concentration camp in Russia
which is nearby park opens another
Sabbath and this was a labor camp you
could take with yourself only what you
can carry
so you didn't carry bedspread so you
know so it seems like that
so my once again was very vivid their
collection is of my uncle negotiating
talking to people maybe someone has a
pillow for the child and eventually he
got hold of a pillow which was partially
torn and you know I can see the dawn
and breaking away flying going around
but it was a pillow it was named luxury
was great thing so I had this kind of a
pillow for good my my cell phone which
was great thing but I do have very vivid
memory of arriving there okay that's
this once again this is not like you
know you can get a picture this once
again because this was in a total
contrast was not moving from area that's
a six bedroom apartment to a two-bedroom
one-bath apartment it was like moving
from two different planets and you know
we were living that we must have seen
photographs or whatever in in those I do
column had parents and they've income
kind of that falls a certain Oh baby
20 25 inches of head space I should say
body space so you really had the
crawling
they held kind of a family discussion of
what to do and they decided that hands
tend better chances in getting out
trying to be on my own and there were
there was a practical problem of first
of all how are they going to break the
news to me I ever had this whole
discussion was going for a couple of
nights so I knew what's coming so my
reaction was very very calm as a matter
of fact this guy pen pal was supposed to
start to stage intervention at the gate
they trying to cool the guards attention
away with a bottle of vodka which he
somehow cut and at that time they gave
me the address and they decided that it
was it was a pretty straight walk so I
was supposed to walk out at once again
we had this party talk tied the stuff
for me and my mother gave me
which you know speaking logically for
the stupid thing to do but to me it
meant really everything mother gave me
her student ID high school ID with a
picture in it says when you keep my
picture no so when we meet again
when we meet again but was what does it
mean
they said to me that when the walls long
to animate promise the war is going to
end they're going to come for me and I
realized after many many years how much
what does it mean for me to promise
something when you promise something is
no matter what happened Forsett
astrophys what hardships do you have to
overcome what does it mean to you if you
give your word if you promise something
you have to do it there is no way out
this is what I believed in this way to
me it was as you know this that's fine
if they say that they are coming for me
they will come and I this is something
that kept me going I don't remember the
work particularly I remember the place
that I got to now I didn't know at that
point that it was a home house people
were living on average of society what
kind of help boots were one another and
should being Jewish meant automatically
be included on the marginal size of
society I met some people around it
showing this address and they told me
this is your house over there but I I
remember someone a woman opening the
door now remember only women to me they
were all dressed in white and everything
in this house was white and only later I
realized why because when I got in
they gave me a glass of milk and this
was how this milk kind of covered
everything white so after the room we
were kind of trying to retrace the Oh
deal or I went and so on so forth
I thought you know I said it was a
hospital and my parents kind of laughed
I didn't know the years afterwards when
I was you know sometimes mentioning the
hospital I was considered for marijuana
so they said now that that taught me the
real story that it was really a whole
house I stayed there for about three
months and after three months it was
folded down by the Germans who took the
women to work for them Army
installations like they used to and at
that point I was after long and I say
laughter now is not heroics it's not
exactly true because I wasn't alone
still other children orphans displays
roaming the streets
I know you ganged up with other kids and
you lived according to the laws of
nature I mean no one was there to tell
us that it's I'm talkin to steal that
it's not becoming to begged I was I was
really lucky because I was blond those
kind of straw blonde and so I didn't
really resemble a Jew yes one one whole
point was that my parents told me that
no matter what happens now don't let
your pants down okay don't let your
pants down and I had the sense of being
different of being Jewish as a matter of
fact it was the summer which we all
missed rates and some suppose then came
a time in which don't need to be cold
and I had the good luck I was begging
one day and a Polish woman took me and
somehow the husband of this woman got
involved in some black market activities
or whatever it wasn't they got arrested
once they got arrested I was
on my own did they know do you think
that you were a Jew I probably probably
they did that's probably a little bit to
meet syriza although it sounds like to
do it at that point I was like seventy
years old I was a real old man I was
short but I was old you know the whole
responsibility of the whole world for
myself this was I knowed it no this is
what I have to finally rely upon this is
myself well it was autumn 1944 and once
again not being on the streets it was an
old lady who lived in a cellar it's you
know it's kind of under on the ground
apartment small apartment and she picked
me up I mean once again I met him she
brought me to her house and he turns out
that she was living with the grandson
and her son beings doing some forced
labor in Germany and and the grandson
died of weeks before she met me
so she was feeling the grieving process
and I think that this helped me in the
way that she wanted someone to live with
and
first of all it was the first time that
I had papers and they used to be buried
in the challenge and always not making
it legal probably thinking about selling
the papers or whatever now papers at the
time were was they probably the waiting
or the size in diamonds not in gold and
so I was I was giving his papers and I
had a name okay so my first name was
much attention ski which is a purely
polish name it has great sound would you
say it again much attention ski that's
met you rainbow and this was also but
this time I was kind of her semi and
worthy my autonomy was curved understand
because I became you know this woman's
grandson so I had to do a few things
which I didn't know how to do is to pray
I have to learn the prayers and I had to
go to church
the prayers I found I didn't like and
they like to depress I wouldn't say that
when it was out of the service of my
Jewishness but I didn't like to recite
our Father and whatever but I didn't
like it and as primitive as this lady
was say that she had a wonderful sense
of what's important it was not important
and by that time I revealed to her that
I have a treasure and I see the picture
of my mother's
so she agreed it every night before
bedtime I will pray like I suggested to
the picture of my mother rather than to
the crucifix you know picture of Jesse
Jesus or whatever it was I used to put
this picture on pray God make this war
and please black my mother come back and
get me at that time it was the winter of
1944 it was very cold and I was wasn't
miserable that time we didn't have love
to eat and life was very hard at that
time so it turned out that this woman
had a sister who was living in a village
nearby that were far from and she sent
me to her sister by the way the sister
was hiding a woman a Jewish woman a her
daughter too they were smaller than her
daughter she was older than I was and
the interesting thing was that the
sister that I came with didn't know that
this that her sister is hiding Jews okay
so of course she didn't tell her sister
that I am NOT a grandson that I am a Jew
the cheese hiding okay so for couple of
months I was living there not knowing
that the same house two more people are
hiding but the funnest thing about it is
funny
is that's this all to the woman and I
was staying in a house while I said to
her husband tonight I'm not going to
sleep at home we're going to the
neighbors whatever said you crazy woman
what do you mean you know and said well
I had this dream which my mother came to
me so she says she says that this house
is unsafe well you know this primitive
Polish setting anyone's mother will
father left you in a dream it's it's a
command so you can't do anything about
it so we left everything and we went to
sleep with the neighbors and the house
was destroyed a bomb on a Jewish I fell
on it and it was worked out so it kind
of makes you wonder it only makes things
more difficult
you must refer to the questions you know
why oh why did I survive there anyway I
met with my parents in the summer of
1945 it was very traumatic meeting I had
the picture of my mother but of course
he didn't she didn't resemble my mother
at all I was still dressed in the prison
camp closed business wild stripes they
will really initiate it and my father
looked terrible he was tortured
and he had all his teeth hanging out you
know it was it was nothing that I had I
just couldn't believe that him little to
tell my parents as a matter of fact I
think this was the hardest part of it
all to accept them again and this was
something we did one hand wanted so
badly to happen and then when that was
confronted with those disfigured people
I just couldn't force myself to go and
connect any contact with them I knew the
government's logically but emotionally I
didn't feel any any any any anything so
much them
I use for some period to address them
and this by calling them mr. and mrs. I
just can't bring myself to accepting
them it took me a while until I was able
to accept them something that kind of
have haunted me for many many years and
once I was safe again I suppose this is
where I disintegrated I develop the face
I can sleep
I started having nightmares liveness
they were totally abstract but they were
always repeating they'll feed themselves
the cannabis three themes that
eventually boil down to kind of a
surrealistic abstract representation of
a feeling of helplessness first like a
conveyor belt okay which I was moving
toward
address
it was rolling over the world price and
she was no power whatsoever to stop it
I couldn't move cause the swirling
closer and closer and I would wake up
totally disoriented crying my head off
through the streaming stop sweat and
shaking
I couldn't I could never go back to
sleep
and this went on for many years until at
one time I I stopped dreaming I know
that it sounds weird because you never
stop dreaming but I somehow managed
totally to repress all dreams and I felt
them free from dreaming I'm telling this
particular so the goal in mind and when
that's around called me initially and
asked me if I'd be willing to
participate in this program my initial
reaction was no I said why don't you
sing little said okay
but I this resolves at that time that
I'm not going to do it it was really
from the sphere of once again trying to
revive the sense that I was trying so
hard to repress accorded rear end is my
wife ask you what it was all about and I
told her and she said that what are you
afraid of my said when I'm scared and
I'm really scared everything will come
back and my nightmare song so far said
well you know you've been living with
this thing now for 34 35 years after the
war you still afraid you've never talked
about it and he didn't what because he
was still afraid still anxious so why
don't you give it try it the other way
and we spent a lot of time talking about
it I started to see the logic
and it's particularly I know we went to
bed very early in the morning also we
talked sit for a better part of the
night and next night I had my nightmares
again but this time it was different
was again the conveyor belt to the game
the rolling process was again the
feeling of hopelessness and terrible
anxiety and for the first of time in my
life I have stopped the conveyor belt I
woke up still feeling very anxious you
know this anxiety is turning to a
wonderful sense of fulfillment and
satisfaction I got up for the first time
I wasn't disoriented I knew where I was
I knew what happened and some of the
first time I was able to do it I feel
strongly that it has to do with the fact
that I decided to open up discussing
that has to do with the fact that have
it's been too long
request we have to come up we have to
talk about it
and therefore I had the salt if you
participate in this kind of problem is
it only for the sake of the other people
I think that for me it serve another
purpose the personal one trying to deal
with my feelings so I said in the
beginning for the past 35 years I've
been trying to convince myself that it
never happened that I oh yeah it may be
it happened but I wasn't affected I
worked
and the rain without getting wet
this was my fantasy it's only now I
started to realize how my whole life was
really shaped by those experiences but
it took me a while to realize
think that our chocolate right now one
of the things that our travel versus if
we don't deal with our feelings we don't
understand our experience what are we
doing to our children
I realized it when my first daughter was
born a very short moment I suspected it
might be something that I'm doing as a
reaction and this was right before right
after I delivered her I delivered my
children myself being a gynecologist and
that privilege was very important to me
so I went on a kind of a - spree buying
spree but it was still a spree binge I
spent a couple of hundred pounds on toys
I put all kinds of toys that you usually
don't buy for a newborn like electric
train like a pedal car I've very proudly
prepared everything in the room my
daughter was three days old when she
came home I thought my wife looked at me
the things and she said why did you buy
all this what do you mean why did that
angle distance child needs to have twice
said yes what you see to take years
before she'll be able to face them what
what women to take is the child makes
toys I just put some totes what's wrong
with the child having toast and it took
me a long time to realize what I was
doing I was finally buying toys for
myself
and this was mean start of my wandering
freely what I will do in the next
generation then we are as we are
can change some we will never be able to
be ready Kate as what happened we might
try to understand some of the dynamics
but we'll never be able to wipe it out
we always live with us and let's face it
I'm facing it now big question is what
will become those are we transferring
our anxieties our fears our problems to
the generations to come and this is why
I feel
that we are talking here not only of the
last generation like they did like the
term they coined after World War one
this time they're dealing with lost
generations it's not only us it's
similar issues to come and I think that
this is the biggest tragedy
of those that survived
you